get started uh this is the the final
talk then in the 50 years of sat
satisfiability workshop
um we have sasha rasbora speaking a
great pleasure to have him here
he's working he's of course got
extensive uh
contributions on the theory side of
complexity
that and other areas but i think he's
it sounds like he's talking on a more
applied topic today illustrating the
interaction between theory and applied
but we'll find out in just a minute
but he's working on time and space and
depth and width
so thank you all right so thank you very
much sam the first thing
i was going to say that it will be a
purely theoretical
or a talk unlike the previous one but i
feel
i should not let you down i will try to
make it
something out of it and actually it is
it is a quite applied talk in the sense
that i believe that no one
the people in this workshop at this time
they need not be convinced the proof
complexity is important and particularly
those parts of roof complexity that deal
with
our weak proof systems like resolution
and resolution will be the main hero
during this talk i will skip all the
motivations
and indeed at least i believe
that all complexity measures main
complexity measures with study and proof
complexity they
are somehow maybe not directly
maybe they look different when they go
to the practical domain but still they
correspond to something in the practical
world
and it turns out when you start doing
these things
then something very strange happens
complexity measures and concepts about
about propositional proofs that when
they were defined
they really did not have
it was not clear whether there should be
somehow related to each other turns out
that there are
very many relations and so that's the
picture
from our new paper where we tried to
put on one or
in one place what is known about those
regulations and actually
my talk will be mostly to explain this
picture
so uh it's uh it's cool and it's
unexpected and there is something behind
it and in many cases
we really don't understand what is
behind it
so let's let's start let's
start hit start let's start
slow so i believe
that at this point i don't have to tell
anyone
what is a resolution proof system so
just in case it is here or the weakness
rule
is cosmetic it's not here but if you
want we can
you can you can take it it's not
important so
so can you see my mouse sam
yes exactly yes also
i think the only thing to
get from this slide the only message is
the annotation sr
stands for the resolution size
and and
that's our picture there is uh
not much on it so far uh so a direction
proof size is absolutely at the bottom
so every singles in a sense will be just
a relaxation of resolution
size and as you can see i take log we
will see
we will also see we will see so why it
is natural and important symptom
so in order to compare airplane oranges
you have earth so
you should have apple interactions let's
compare apples and apples first
so this is the seconds in importance
probably
uh proof complexity measure for
resolution so i mean it was defined by
resolution but if you think about it
then there is
nothing about resolution here you simply
if you have an arbitrary function or an
arbitrary constraint
in w variables then you can always
express it as a set of clauses of course
so it's uh
inherently symmetrical merger it simply
means that all
concepts you use in your profile in your
algorithm depend on at most
w variables so and it is the obvious
observation
it's simply based on the fact that the
right hand side
it so it is a bound on the overall
number of classes of
width w and
as i said i prefer to take logarithms
everywhere
so and when we take logarithms and we
see that log
of resolution size is roughly w
only we have here this new log n factor
so one thing i am going to argue today
about is that
if you consider proof complexity
measures in this region
then it is a very natural and very
answer when you start doing things and
you see why it is natural is so
allow both logan factor
and polynomial overheads then
the picture really becomes structural
and it becomes very nice
you can just see that things
come together so it is clearly
well it it means obviously that mu 1 is
smaller than mu 2 and me 2 is smaller
than mu 1.
so one remark is that this or the
strategy which is good
motion of simulation and another remark
is that size
normal size measures will appear today
under the log
sign which means that in the
standard cochlear framework or it
corresponds to quasi-polynomial
simulations
well it's not the main focus of this
talk but i would
i would perhaps like to mention that
we see uh improved complexity we see
why the polynomial simulations coming up
naturally
in many different contexts
like there are there's been a recent
great paper on cutting planes and
stubbing planes and you see that
quasi-polynomial comes in
very naturally and maybe not for not so
dissimilar
reasons to us anyway uh
that's our main concept of simulation
then uh of course this means that as
sr is locus r is at most widths
let's put it on the picture right
so now we have at least something here
and of course
we know that this is or this is proper
it shares a simulator it is or these two
measures are separated
in the strongest possible sense it is
the result by banan carissa
20 years ago and uh
right it was or
it was meant as a separation for
pensacon wickerson
simulation uh what's uh business of
interest on its it is not in this
framework
uh if you know what it is because it has
extra
n vector and we calculate and factors
here i mean
and factor in the exponent
all right good let's move on
so uh the next
uh
station or the next stop is three like
residual flip size
well in this community uh
well again i think most people know that
real like resolution correspond
corresponds to gpl you cannot do too
much with dpl
you have to do other things
but still sierra decorates uh nice and
important and interesting now to compare
with things
so an easy part of being sasson and
victorson
uh it says that well i mean relatively
easy it
says that her w
is at most lock very like size
and if you are wondering her usually
when people stay things like that they
put the weights
of the rh and lcnf to the right hand
side i don't do it first of all because
i cheat
and second because in our new paper
you can see that how can your slightly
redefine things that you will not need
this annoying term
or you can simply assume that your f is
has constant with whatever you like i
will not put anything on the right hand
side here
and so it was also proven to be
basically died so in the first paper the
idiots here
enter some power and then it was
improved to almost
optimal so now we have the relation
between
rates and of
tree like size
that's where we are now
so far i i'm talking only about
apple's apples means her
size measure ordinary
ordinary proofs
so depths depth is also known in the
logical community as height
you have a proof be it's a deck or
tree like and you look at the longest
path
of at the longest passing this profit is
defined just in
computational complexity of course and
what is obvious this simulation is
obvious just because if you have depth g
then you can
somehow or make it into a rotary form
you can
split all branches and you will get a
proof of size at most of the dna
so what is somewhat surprising is that
this is also tight and i say surprising
because
as you know in complexities here if
instead of proofs you talk about
computations
then it is tight it is called sphero
serum
and it is one of the most basic results
in circuit complexity
that if if you have a depth
uh low depth computation then you can
make a formula
small formula out of it so turns out
that in this world it is precisely the
opposite
and here i would like to at least
mention
some of the most important
uh some of the most importants
are apologies or cnrfs or
that are used for separations in this
this business hits a foreign formulas
called
pebbling contradiction we bring
contradictions
sometimes so we have a dag
say with one source and one zinc st
a st deck and we form basically this
horn formula
which is written here we simply says
that we simply say that if i have
approved x1 x2 and x3 if i if i
approve all immediate predecessors of x4
then i can
insert infer x4 also
and i start with s and i want to
refill t and this simple observation
is that the tree-like size
a resolution size of the refutation of
this formula is at most
n reaches are written here
and it mirror it is simply because i
just
uh infer these variables
one after another corresponding to the
vertices of this
duck
and work hard
or a lsd record proved that the depth
of this thing is bounded from below by
the
black only public grammy complexity of
german and
since we know that
there are binary meaning orphaning so
graphs gn with large beveling complexity
it also
implies that
the separation between those two
measures
so what else can i say here so it turns
out
and i believe it was introduced in our
paper that
uh it is convenient and we need that
we will need it for one of our results
what is it uh it is convenience where
so uh uh
introduce another measure complexity
measure which is positive that
we call it positive depth so it actually
means that
whenever we have a reservation
refutation
then we go along this branch
for free for free means that i don't
increment
depth counter for depth depth gets
increased only on this branch
on this branch so why it is called
positive of course because in the
implementation if you view it as
i don't know an algorithm then it
corresponds to assigning
x to one not to zero we want to falsify
this c
all right good so we have a question
yep yeah so the part the number of
negative literals do you mean the number
of times you have uh resolved on
a negative literal clause or just yes
yes sir
it's three like it's true yes so it does
not
you can assume that it's regular
okay so so okay so it seems regular yeah
or it's so it's about depth so we can
easily hear that it's really like
so and it's it's local which it means
that it is
maximum number a longer paths so if you
look at this thing then
it's it's not clear that it is even
montreal
right looks like we allowed ourselves
lots of freedom maybe we get something
stupid here turns out that it is not
non-verbal
first of all one obvious fact is that
it is of course smaller than that
because less things
and less obvious fact is but very easy
is that actuary it is larger again
within uh the precision vital airway
it is larger than lock over three legs
let me just show you the problem because
this recurrence
uh it's a this recursion it
it appears over and over in this
business it
appears many times it's the same
recursion
so and so it's very easy so if i want to
bound
that really like size uh in terms of the
number of variables and positive depths
are as we did on the previous slide
so i simply recurs according to the
resultation rule at the top
and along good branch
we have that are both positive depths
and n decreases by one but
something happens even along the path
branch we
don't increment positive depths but the
number of variables drops
so we have this recursion and you know
what it converges
so in this kind of calculation
our computation appears all the time
let's see things so insert
the observation it's it stands for
negative
you have to negate things but anyway
that duration is that
if you look at oracle cards proof then
it actually separates
positive depth from both depths and
story like size both these things are
optimal so it's very easy to see let me
skip it
so now we have all apples on
our picture so it's a nice
uh chirac here where we can separate
every
of resolution curves with resolution
problems
so apples look like looker logarithms
let's now talk about
oranges because that's what is
interesting here
so somehow when you talk about proofs
of the same nature it's somewhat
not very surprising and they are related
what is surprising is that when
we completely change the gears
and talk about space complexity then we
still
have lots of relations
and we will see right
so this this
bunch of definitions i again believe
most people here know it's
space complexity it's uh
captures the situation where we really
care
what we keep on our whiteboard or in our
memory if you're around run ctcl for
example solver whether it's or
you raise something or not and the
general definition goes like this so
almost almost always it will be just a
set of clauses but i don't want
to commit myself traits and we have just
these three rules
you can either download your original
clause or an axiom into your memory
you can apply inference rule or it's
written here for resolution but you can
do it every
everywhere else and you can erase
something
just in this way
your safe on memory
and you can reduce memory for other
things after example
again so it's well studied a class of
models
and a configurational proof is just a
sequence of configurations like that you
start with
empty set of formulas and you want to
infer
a contradiction and so you measure
complexity of a configuration what you
have in memory
at every particular moment and
[Music]
also then the
usual stuff the complexity of a
refutation will be the maximum over all
these things and so this will be
the minimum over all refutations so it
is
i here i go over those complexity
measures
that will be needed for my talk so
and there is a bit of terminological
confusion here for which i am part and
responsible
so let me just uh
state here a clause space is uniquely
different is the number of classes you
keep in your memory at every particular
time
variable space is the overall number of
variables you keep in there in the
memory
and with repetitions which means
that if if what variable occurs several
times you count it only once and if your
columns are all variables in classes in
a given configuration
into a right as many times as they
appear
then you will get just the bit size
which is
called total space so these are
the measures that i will need
all right and very interesting results
and so then uh all of a sudden turns out
that this thing's defined totally differ
differently from our first part
they turned out to be related first of
all
uh right it's not chronological or it's
great a result
that our bounds rates in terms of plus
space again i
skip everywhere this annoying term for
good reasons
and in the original paper exterban and
foreign show that it is bound by
log st and so by the way
you don't have to rush and read
my formulas on the slides it's mostly
for the records
but everything will be shown on the
picture of course
essentially it says it separates w
francis
from class p turns out that separation
between clause space
and st is a major open problem that we
will discuss
interest of my talk extensively
okay so and and our our results
are let me know that it is very weak
because i don't have log here
so it is what it says plus races
are constant and sir we can come up with
uh or
pathologies where tree-like size is at
least quadratic and you can improve it
or
generalize it so you can put key here
and then it will be m2tk
but still it is extremely weak
but so that's the only thing which is
known in terms of
uh this results how to eat it how tight
it is
at least we believe so and also
uh so uh
and it is for this probe that we need
positive depth
it comes in very naturally
all right okay so now
that's what we have we have introduced
clause space
and for some strange reasons it's uh
it's a
it is uh between these two respectful
measures
and now we don't need this
this thing so it follows from what is
here
let me before i will so i have two more
things to discuss let's talk about
variable space
so variable space are it is
obviously bounded by reads because
fossils just talk about the same thing
the number of variables
if i have variable space or then where
it is simply all classes will have width
w atmos w
you will have a proof of this complexity
so oracle card also proves that it is
bounded
by depth
and uh
ben sasson are in our he is a
very very actual interesting paper of
online
he did not uh though
he didn't talk about positive depth he
was talking about claw space here
but sir if you look at
so here separated variable space from
class space but sir if you look at what
he did
or how can you easily adapt his proof
then it goes up to positive depth
so uh
uh it's just it was actually earlier
than the result by working hard i
mentioned before
but it's way more difficult and in
particular it uses black white webbing
in order to bound variable space you
need to
have black white building not only
are black purple
[Music]
so here is where we are now
and again here is uh we have one more
letter red arrow here because we
don't know how to these two things
so and so let me
also say something about monomial space
monomial space is now is our first model
which is not
based on resolution namely
uh in resolution we still have a set of
classes in
my memory it's a set of classes
so but in in resolution we simply think
about it as
a conjunction we simply say that
uh right semantically what is in the
memory
it just says that all these classes are
true
so more
general model what we have
we have that the symmetrical contents of
my memory m it is
determined as an arbitrary function f
in the set of those classes
and in the most general model or it can
be
essentially everything but so but the
model which
people mostly are mostly interested here
in this context it is called
polynomial calculus with resolution or
you fix your fields
and your view at this things
at negation of classes as monomials over
that field and that explains
that there are monomial space and your
can write down a bunch of polynomials
with
those monomials as terms so
anyway uh all the results that i am
going to mention
they are they are true for an arbitrary
for functional calculus you can put
everything in the memory as long as it
is a function of classes
and now what we have
here here
we again have this that first of all the
obvious observations it
is that this thing is below
law space and so very interesting
observation
in what observations the deep theorem is
that actually again for some
unclear reasons we
have
that w is smaller than m space
after a square and
so an interesting open equation is
whether this square can be removed
or because it will give lots of things
or
it's much easier to get lower bounds on
w than on
m space and in the opposite direction we
do not
have a separation so the only
the basic as far as i know in terms of
separation between
w and m space is this working progress
so it gives you a quadratic separation
and quadratic is not enough
all right here this is where we are now
and all right
so let me this error
goes away but more reluctantly
or because it still creates information
we can separate
weights and close space but we cannot
separate
we don't know which one is
different right so now uh
i have to explain the other stuff
most of most of it are is start so let
me start with this analogy
or the motivating question is uh
if you have a limited space then for how
long
can you survive learning different
stories
and if you like science fiction
as much as i do then people
speculate what are the difficulties here
are building a spaceship that goes from
earth or
some distant star and
one part of this speculation is that
this place in your ship is very limited
and so there are
these places where limited and people
tell stories and at some point there and
out of story starts becomes
repeated it creates psychological
problems so
i know at least one or maybe so pieces
of science fiction that speculate
about this thing so that in very limited
space
you really can trail only a bounded
number
of different stories
so in our framework we have uh
that we have very long proof certainly
if stories start repeating themselves if
m
k is equal to ml for different k l then
we are obviously in trouble
because it means that we did not make
any progress
the part between mk and ml is lost
is lost on us we did not do anything or
it can be removed
it's not good when stories repeat
themselves answer
how many different stories you can you
can tell
these are these are the balance
so it shares well
exponent of this thing is the obvious
bound
on the number of a family of s-classes
and so it is everything you can express
as functions here in s variables
and here it is simply because
if if i give you s variables then you
have two to the two to the
s different boolean functions and
in red here there are problematic
terms why why it can be large it can be
large here because
even when as is constant you may have
many different configurations and here
you can uh
have many boolean functions and the
question is whether it is
whether it can really happen because
stories
it they should be meaningful they should
be
our proof it should be a part of our
proof
and the
best way to ask this question is to
infrared use
this variance
of complexity measures
if i have space complexity measured then
instead of just measuring
the complexity of my
configurational proof i am artize it or
regularize by log of
its length i penalize for particularly
long proofs
[Music]
and then turns out that our picture
if you introduce this star turns out
that our
picture becomes extremely much
better light so this picture is sort of
so imprecise right you have lots of
measures
and they move around and some of them
are comparable some of them are not
comparable turns out that
if you look at the amortized versions of
them
then everything becomes just very neat
so and here is what happens if you
ignore
non-start versions and turns out that
amortized
versions of everything
or at least of many things we are
interested in
are space complexity
they just fit our picture precisely they
fit one of these two levels
and there will be a third level so
that's the picture that you get and
now i have to explain a bit
the remaining uh yell still yellow stuff
on it
so let us uh let us do it uh
as i already mentioned and and i will
actually
and so the rest of my talk will be you
know what it's
devoted to discussing this issue as i
already mentioned it is major open
problem for many complexity measures
whether
amortization really helps whether
really long proofs exist
so here is the only
general fact that that i am aware of
so you will be here your complexity
measurement
will correspond look a response to
both ordinary measure
and amortized version it will correspond
to that
according to our relation
so in this in this case if
it is if it is coming from a circuit
class
and such that it is intermediate
it is bounded from below by the number
of variables and
from about by this circuit size
according to this class so total space
it fits here variable and class space
things we are most interested in they
fail this criterium variable space it
fails the second part boolean functions
that you have in variable variable space
they can be totally non-constructive
they may not correspond to even
unbounded circuits and plus
it fails in the first criterion
namely clause space can be much smaller
than the number of variables
so answer in the chain of inequalities
in our paper you also
have regular entry-like class space
so and just a few words about the gmf
retardation space or that we also
introduced
so uh in this or in this model
or now it's slightly more complicated
one level more complicated in memory
we now keep our dmf
right instead of classes we keep gaining
formulas and turns out
that it is convenient now we have to
measure speeds it is convenient to
measure the space as the sum of
widths of formulas in my memory
why well first of all because
this this was started
in many uh
if i started several papers for
the case of constant weights
so and sir it was formula space and we
are consistent because
then you are just after a constant
factor it is just our definition and of
course
the main answer is that this is all for
a difficult
and somehow complicated model turns out
that it is the same as with spirit
well up for certain actually this part
it is surprisingly tight it is simply
the same
up to a constant factor it just
describes
so and i i'm almost out of time and i
still have a few slides so
let me show the last
uh system where it was considered by
young right check
so it is this system in which the reads
which is a subset of dnf results in
which
the rates of all classes is bounded by a
given function
like log function uh in the size
and again for some reasons that we
really don't understand
turns out that it will be a tree like
reservatory like
proofs in this pro system are again the
same as weeds
and remarkably i think well you can
spoil
any proof by making it
direct but
our proof deserts or size
measures or at least uh measures
corresponding to normal proofs
the natural way of doing it is to use
sigma to speeds
at least in one direction so that's
that's the thing that actually occurs
many times
and so it's uh in ld6 that
if you want to prove that something is
related then it is better to use
something else as an intermediate it's
how we do things in complexity theory as
well everyone here
right so it is just the repeats of
my first slide now we are officially
done and now we know
what all these things are about and i
think it's a nice picture
and it really shows that there is a bit
of a structure and
now i am moving to the last part of my
talk
which is basically open problems only
i will i will add a few annotations
since
in my view and i think in view of many
uh
all open problems are here on this slide
these are these thin red errors
these are fundamental problems to prove
that these measures
they are really separated so here is
if we make my notation let's start with
variable space so
as you can see uh
given given that we have really several
big clusters
uh all these things are equivalent to
lottery things
so first of all it is the same as asking
work of heart creation with their depth
can you pound it by variable space he
did it in the opposite direction
and also if you don't know what it means
i don't have time to go into details but
it's a it means that you want to
have a traitor which is super critical
in the sense
that low variable space proof
must be really huge and here
is what we can do in this direction
so only separate only quadratic
separation and the proof is shockingly
difficult
and uh if there
are here referees of my paper i
certainly
see here the handling category then i
just want to
send them for the words edit on it and
apologize for its complexity i try to
simplify it
but somehow it's not clear
how far you can go it's awfully
difficult proof
so the next law space
versus uh
amateurish or class space and it's where
it's also
either equivalent or quasi equivalence
or
a few of other questions well the first
or
clear question that was asked
in the seminal paper by esteban and
store and whether
you can go in another way you
have a small class space can you get a
small tree-like
case a small tree like there is no
refutation it's all equivalent
jacobs are asked a question so whether
you can
you can do this thing
so if you have small class space
refutations and by
at serious dalmow you have a small
weights enhanced panano meal size
uh refutation he asked
or jacob i mean asked whether you can do
it simultaneously
it's a great question also equivalent to
this one and you can also
phrase it as asking about super critical
thread
between clays claw space and depths
so hence i guess you can continue that
this is
since amortized clause space it really
corresponds to many things
so you can ask lots of things here lots
of things there
so monomial space
and class space or i guess this question
some people at least here they spent a
considerable time on it
the only comment i can make here is that
our structural picture it explains some
difficulties
because if you separate these two things
then you will also
separate monomial space from its
analog from its amortized version
and so we believe that it will be very
difficult
that the only remark i can make here
again so the last error
is that it is
also quite so embarrassing here
because as i already mentioned we have
results these are quite concrete
actually variants of papering or just be
everything tautology separating w
form class piece and we really don't
know what is
monomial space for these technologies so
you might think that you would be able
to analyze
to analyze them and i guess the
conjecture is that they are hard
but that's what we are missing and
absolutely
the last slide i am several minutes
over time so let me
just say briefly that
we have four resolution features areas
of one
we have we have one picture for
resolution locker resolution we have
another picture and it is
natural to ask what happens in between
this is uh what can be said from our
approve
and their interesting question is what
happens in between
and for example whether very like
say repetitory-like procedures probe
system they are the same as
small formula space proofs in the same
system so that's the last open question
also on the same form so and so that's
basically what i wanted to say
uh there is a nice and rich
structure here and so it will be really
interesting to fill in the remaining
caps because these are
rare fundamental systems thank you
thank you very nice talk very thorough
so we have a plenty of time for
questions so uh
please us speak up and ask questions
and um
so in in your uh amortized your star
definitions i want to get a um a sort of
more fundamental
intuition of why you uh why you think of
it
that way why you pick that particular uh
formulation for the uh going
yes yes that's paul speaking i cannot uh
i think i can do it
it works in many contexts so it's a
natural thing totally first of all as i
said ali started it he did not call it
new star
but he ameritized by this thing and when
you're just uh
you're probably paul you're probably
asking about why log why not something
else
yes uh what else
what else it's it's either constant or
log or
or just or just p and it's it's it's the
right size and
the main motivation is that it is the
right regularization factor
well since i am since i mentioned this
water regularization then let me
perhaps also mention that
you you put here
multiplication again because it
naturally comes improves
after a polynomial you can put here
additions and it will be just
the normal regular regularization you
use
in learning theory in machine learning
you can you can put plus here and where
it will change
yeah that's uh i think it works uh
there are more actually no or almost no
alternatives to
it answer
it's uh i think the best explanation is
that you have
this picture
sure so it clearly works well
it works well and there are all their
sorry possibilities and
uh the other two are ridiculous
okay and why i missed some a basic point
about that why is it called
amortized or
why it is called americanist i
thought it so it's right english word
but now
it is an english word it usually means
where you take like average cost over
multiple steps right so you have an
amortized algorithm which means that
sometimes
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so now now when
you
mention it then i i
start having doubts my by myself maybe
regularization is the better better word
okay amortization amortization
yes i think you are right maybe maybe a
regularization is a better word
work we find anyway we punish for
exceeding player
long probes okay
uh let's see there's a comment in the
chat window from zaid's
swap many theorems were cited from
articles how to get a list of the
references
well it's a it's it's all in our paper
it's very simple
so uh well take take our paper
it's on my website it's uh or on
theodore's website
it is uh if you're if you are on the pro
complexity marketing list then you
got even a link and all references
that i have cited today are in our paper
it's very simple
and more connections because i get to
skip something today
and uh more questions
so i did miss earlier
you threw away some of your blue arrows
where separations were known was that
just to save space on the slot
screen or or which one well you had some
arrows
i think it got added again the one on
the right hand side is that one right on
the left-hand side
yeah there's a a lighter blue arrow and
darker blue arrows so that's maybe all
right right there
here yeah yeah well it's it's it's
here is light blue because we know
inclusion
but we don't know separation okay oh no
no no no
sorry sorry sorry i mean are what i'm
saying
we have separation here right
but we don't need the inclusion because
it follows from these two things
okay it's our
like p p space and x time right
we know that p is in explain but we can
draw its
wire space and we cannot separate
anything here
so hands
[Music]
yes this one we don't need it entirely
because it follows from this thing
right both separation and
the inclusion
and so this one it it is just so
yeah so it's the same error from the
first slide and i just removed it here
most of my picture
i think it is really embarrassing that
we can separate
which from class space but we have zero
idea which one of this is
actually separated right
so anything else on chat or it isn't the
same
um oh yes mark mark mark mark
mark posted a link to your paper small
space
oh let's see people want that they to
look at the paper right now they can
grab the link out of the chat window
good
um any other questions comments
uh it's your last chance to ask a
question in the
50 years of sat meeting so i'm double
shy and otherwise
if no one speaks up real fast we're
gonna wrap things up
all right so uh thank you again very
much i clap on behalf of everybody
uh i think we had a wonderful set of
speakers including
the final ones today uh it's been a
great experience to do all this so
uh thank you for all those who attending
and before you run away
uh antonina is going to post a gather
town link in just a moment if you want
us to talk informally and gather town
for a few minutes
i think i believe i should stop sharing
right
uh okay good yes but we can see
everybody now better
i think i just did this and there is a
there is the town hall meeting in about
uh 30 minutes also
for after the gather town meeting so we
have plenty of chances to interact
and antonina do you have anything to add
about the town hall meeting
um not my just uh
can you see me we'll start the town hall
in what about half an hour
and um if people want to say something
please let me know if you decide to say
something during the meeting
uh you you could message me or andre
during the meeting
uh it will be fairly informal just
what do we do from there now that the
program is over
so hope to see you there in half an hour
and maybe before that on gather town
very good thank you and the gather town
link is now in the chat window
so all right i think that's the end of
this meeting then so uh
see you guys possibly in gather town but
definitely in the town hall meeting in
30 minutes
for those who can make it good and thank
you again
sasha and armin for the great talks
today
thank you